So I said there were 2 main differences between strings and lists.
The first we've seen already is that a list can hold
anything we want, whereas a string, the elements could only be characters.
The second big difference between lists and strings
is that lists support mutation.
Mutation sounds a little bit scary, and in some ways it is scary.
It makes it much harder to understand what our programs mean,
but it's also very powerful.
What mutation means is we can change the value of a list
after we've created it.
To explain what that means and to see why it's so different
from the behavior we can get with strings,
let's recap what happens with strings.
We can create a string. We can store it in a variable.
We can change the value of the variable
by creating a new string.
So what's going on there, it's changing the value of s,
but it's not changing the value of the string.
When we did the first statement, this one,
it created a string with the value "Hello,"
and it introduced a variable, s, which referred to that string.
When we execute the second statement,
that creates a new string
with the value "Yello," and it changes s
to refer to that new string.
It hasn't changed the string that we created with the value Hello.
We just don't have a way to refer to that any more.
With strings, we can also use the + operator to concatenate 2 strings.
It looks like this is changing the value of the string.
You might think that the result of this is, well, now the string
that was previously Yello spelled wrong is now Yellow
spelled with the w added at the end.
But that's not actually what happens.
We don't actually modify the string we had.
What happens when we use the + operator,
it creates a completely new string where the value of the new string
is the result of concatenating the 2 input strings.
When we execute the third statement,
first a new string with the value w is created.
Then when we do the concatenation,
it doesn't modify the previous string that we've created.
It creates a whole new string
which will have the value "Yellow" spelled with a w.
And then the assignment changes what s refers to
to refer to the new string.
Now let's see what we can do with lists.